I want you to understand  how good a woman your mama was  she took Colton Briggs the coldest  killer that I've ever met and she turned  him into a family man  my mama's dead now  [Applause]  or another  tell me the names of the men who did  this as long as that little girl is  alive  there's no room for vengeance  [Music]  you're protecting a killer  from another killer  can you teach me how to shoot  yeah well then you put your hands behind  your back now Brig especially that Rossi  my father wants you done I'll blow her  brains all over this Valley  he's getting scared of nothing  Briggs decides he's coming  Colton Graves is coming he's here sound  like he's the one who scared  my whole life I'd seen fear in the eyes  of every man I ever met  let's do this the old way is my father  still all good man  you boy [ __ ] up the devil  foreign  [Music]